when mackenzie scott and jeff bezos
ended their marriage she walked away
with 34 billion dollars worth of amazon
stock
since then she's given away a portion of
that massive post-divorce fortune at a
faster pace than any billionaire ever
distributing at least 8.6 billion
dollars in less than two years
compare that to the estimated lifetime
giving of her ex-husband jeff bezos who
is notoriously more stingy with his
charitable
donations however bezos donated enough
in the past year to make our top givers
list for the first time announcing one
billion dollars in donations the most
he's given away since amazon went public
in 1997.
the bezos earth fund a 10 billion pledge
from bezos gifted 443 million dollars to
environmental organizations
the bezos day one fund distributed 96
million dollars to nonprofits helping
homeless families in 2021
he also gave 100 million dollars to the
obama foundation
and just before bezos flew in his blue
origin rocket in late july 2021 the
smithsonian's national air and space
museum announced a 200 million dollar
gift from bezos
the museum didn't disclose the time
period over which the gift will be paid
much of it will go towards establishing
an education center aptly named the
bezos learning center
he famously shared his priorities in an
interview with charlie rose back in 2016
saying he would try to match fellow
billionaire bill gates's prolific
philanthropy if there is anything left
after i finish building blue origin
since then he became the world's richest
person he's now either number two or
number three richest depending on the
day and has faced more calls to share
his wealth
that seems to have edged on his giving
in sharp contrast his ex-wife scott
talks about giving away her wealth until
the safe is empty
she doesn't have a website or a fund
with her last name on it and doesn't
talk much publicly about her
philanthropy outside what she shares on
the blogging site medium
in 2020 she disclosed that she had
donated 5.8 billion dollars to 500
different groups across the country
in june of last year she announced she
gave another 2.7 billion dollars in
gifts to 286 high-impact groups such as
the children's defense fund and the
national council of non-profits
then in december scott posted that she'd
made another round of gifts she didn't
give out any details just clarifying
that she would share details about the
gifts in the year to come and announced
she'd be launching a website with a
searchable database of gifts
so far scott has donated to more than
780 organizations focusing on causes
including racial justice gender equality
and public health she focuses less on
the big ticket and well-funded names
like the smithsonian or princeton
university instead selecting grassroots
and hyperlocal community groups like
homeboy industries in los angeles el
paso community college in texas and the
women's funding network
[Music]